gonna tell you a little bit about the
dying light universe
so stay tuned
every tragedy begins somewhere this one
started with a virus that escaped from
haran
the city we met in the first part of the
game
and it reached the whole world including
the city
where dying light 2 takes place remember
january 6
2025 that day later known as black
monday
the military ordered chemicals to be
dropped on the city
it was a mistake a huge mistake
the chemicals mixed with water
penetrated
the soil killing plants turning most
people into blood thirsty monsters
don't think of them as zombies though
they are more like
half-life suffering people who attack
everything that lives
as a result of their pain and rage
those who survived the chemical raid
took refuge on the rooftops
a new order has been born in the city
people live on rooftops
monsters in the streets nobody in their
right mind would dare to calm down
well let's say almost nobody
the exception is the main character of
dying light to
aiden but why is he braver than others
how did he develop such a unique parkour
and combat skills
believe me guys i would gladly answer
all these questions but
i'm not here to spoil it for you let me
tell you one thing
dame nightmare haunts me every night i'm
locked up with other kids
i don't know what he did to me but he
did it every day
over and over looking for something he
couldn't find
the worst part was that he did the same
to my sister
i'll never forget her scream when they
separated us
what could i do they had rifles
and we we were five years old
and there was a fire explosions chaos
i got away soldiers took me out of the
city but my sister
stayed there
my mia i left her
we meet aiden as one of them many many
children
undergoing mysterious medical research
the last thing aiden remembers from that
time
is extreme pain then a fire
and a little girl that was being tested
with him
her name was mia she was his sister
what happened next after the fire is mia
still alive
the following years hunted aidan with
these questions
and with guilt over leaving her
moreover mia is the only answer to the
question
who aiden really is now in 2036
we meet aiden when for the first time
during his pilgrimage
he finds a clue about how to find his
sister
aidan's path to the truth is tough
full of challenges and adventures
the difficult choices to make as well as
their consequences
awaits you you're going to discover them
all
in december 2021
you